hello everybody my name is prestige and
this is minecraft xbox 360 edition the
end yeah at the end alright so this is
it a new title update 9 has been
released April fourth is the equivalent
to 1.1 the pc except with some extra
features i'm going to tell you all the
features while i kill the ender dragon
and yeah I gave myself all the stuff in
crates knowledge it don't worry alright
so get in it let's go the end will be
different from computer the Enderdragon
breeze ender acid and also shoots
projectiles at you just side note exit
portal spawns when you enter at the end
but is only activated when the
Enderdragon is killed he also the
Enderdragon gets caught on the andhra
exit and that makes easier for you and
your crystals up to two of them were
covered by iron bars he had to climb up
spawn eggs stack will to 16x on maps to
show location of the end portal when
someone is in the end she can now regrow
their wool Biden grass readded beaches
bows now stack up to 64 add a new new
music for the end and the nether from
c418 blacksmith's building and villages
now hold chests with the loot on the
same type as found in strongholds added
smoother color transitions between
biomes fence gates can now be opened and
closed with redstone changed nether
fortress to make nether wart rooms more
likely made nether wart spawn randomly
wherever soul sign is generated in the
nether allows players to block with the
sword when the can build and mine option
is unchecked by the host moved six of
the 12 music discs into the tutorial
world in this tutorial would change the
tutorial world to add climbing vines and
some of the new items and removed reduce
the items in the brewing farming and
breeding chests don't show achieved its
warning when loading a creative map that
has already been saved and created
reduce the volume of gas sound effects
increase the distance juice boxes can be
heard from improved lighting code
performance improve the loading save
time change the display order in the
minecraft sorter show newest dlc added
how to play the end and farm animals
added HUD size options for both split
screen and full screen modes added to
reset another option to force
regeneration of the nether added a
toggle for death messages and little to
hide or display the animated care
character in the user interface allow
individual split screen users to have
their own settings for HUD now these are
all the features that aren't in 1.1 but
have been implemented into this one
point two point one features vines can
now be climbed to send a decent fire
change major Spencer dispensed mobs from
spawning strata Nick's a geek self
slabber see recipes give six slabs birch
and spruce wood planks labs and steric
one point three point one the features
buckets now stackable 16 Santa's
sandstone stairs signs enough says
stackable 216 sign recipe- three signs
so matures will now exempt fluid liquids
from a bucket when a redstone pulse and
place liquids back in the buckets after
another pulse change gravel texture
nether wart will not now grow in the
overworld one point four point two
features would button item frame stone
button now requires one block of stone
stuff to trap doors can we can be placed
on half sighs and stares nether brick
slabs and 1.5 features neither bird can
be made bus mill teen another rack there
are some bug fixes fixed fireballs
causing a freeze when entering the
nether fix crash with ender pearls fixed
for cave spider size effects experience
or pick up sound not having a pitch
variants fix a crash when attaching post
on pistons fixed a render update problem
on the end of World chunks stop the
player animation from eating happening
in the change in menu alright that's
everything and I should have put some
epic music in there if I don't slap my
hand and since I was kind of born that
is the end I killed the Enderdragon
hopefully you guys enjoyed this I might
do a play through all like a survival
series of Minecraft Xbox now that new
update is here I don't know depends on
what you guys say so I hope you all
enjoyed if you did leave a like comfort
subscribe you got this far I think it
deserves that much my name's prestige
hooking droid and peace out till next
time